[Music]
welcome back to Harbor onbox today we're
checking out nvidia's new GeForce RTX
3050 now this is the latest addition to
their amp lineup and although it's now
the most low-end 30 series GeForce GP on
offer it's not based on a new piece of
silicon so it's not some tiny little die
rather it's another go16 product and
that means it shares the same silicon as
the RTX 360 but with the MSRP dropped
down from $330 to just
$250 so you can expect quite a lot of
the D to be disabled to justify that cut
in price but before we get to any of
that today's video sponsor is thermal
Grizzly and their cry not extreme which
is now available in a 2 G syringe this
high performance thermal paste delivers
maximum thermal conductivity thanks to
an extremely small particle size and
layer thickness it's also very flexible
capable standing up to subzero
temperatures for extreme overclocking
but also performs exceptionally well for
air and water cooling applications so if
your CPU or GPU needs repasting then I
suggest checking out the thermal Grizzly
range link is in the video
description okay so the core
configuration has been reduced from
3,584 cores to just
2560 so an almost 30% reduction there
but interestingly the same 48 RS remain
although the core boost frequency
Remains the Same at at 1777 MHz the
memory speed has been slightly reduced
from 15 GBS per second to 14 GBS per
second so couple that with the smaller
128bit wide memory bus and we end up
with a pretty significant 38% drop in
memory bandwidth an advantage of these
cutdowns though is a 24% drop in board
power to just 130 W meaning a basic 550
W power supply will be more than
sufficient to power an RTX 350 gaming
system
now when compared to the radon RX 6500
XT the MSRP for the RTX 3050 is 25%
higher at $250 us but of course we
expect that it will retail for much more
than that and we'll look into that
towards the end of the video so although
the RTX 3050 is set to cost more it is a
significantly better product on paper
packing 8 GB of vram PCI times 8
bandwidth four display ports av1
decoding and an actual Hardware encoding
engine so all of the stuff you'd really
expect to see on a modern graphics card
but don't actually get with the 6500 XT
now although Nvidia has cut the full PCI
bandwidth in half which we never like to
see on products priced at or above $200
but with 8 GB of vrm and8 times
bandwidth the PCI 3.0 performance will
be the same as 4.0 in today's games so
the RTX 3050 isn't crippled like the
6500 XT on a PCI 3.0 system so with that
out of the way let's talk about the test
system specs and then jump into the
Benchmark results for testing I'm using
our ryzen 9 550x GPU test system and
yeah I know no one is going to pair a
budget graphics card with this kind of
CPU but that's not the point we're
testing GPU performance here and
therefore we wish to avoid introducing a
CPU bottleneck which would skew the data
as for the data itself everything is
100% fresh for this video I've spent the
last few weeks updating our mid-range
GPU results for the 6500 XT and RTX 3050
reviews and much of the testing has been
done using dial down quality settings
which were felt out using the 4 GB 5500
XT finally testing takes place at 1080P
and 1440p so let's get to it starting
with Assassin's Creed Valhalla using the
medium quality preset at 1080p we find
that the RTX 350 is good for 79 FPS on
average so here it's basically a GTX
1660 super and that made it 18% faster
than the 6500 XT using PCI 4.0 and then
30% faster when compared to the 3.0
configuration it was also only 8% slow
in the RTX 260 so I think a decent
result there overall the 1440p data is
much more favorable for the RTX 3050
when compared to amd's recently released
6500 XT again the 3050 is mimicking the
performance of the 1660 super but that
meant here it was 38% faster than 6500
XT or 45% faster with limiting the rad
on GPU to PCI
3.0 shadow of the Tomb Raider was tested
using the highest quality preset as it
is quite an old game now and the
measuring stick for this testing as I
said earlier was the 4 GB 5500 XT which
was good for over 60 FPS on average
under these conditions so that seemed
reasonable to me the RTX 350 blasted
past that result though with 87 FPS on
average edging it slightly ahead of the
1660 super this time that made it 34%
faster than the 6500 XT or 85% faster
when limiting the 6500 XT to PCI 3.0 so
super easy win here for NVIDIA and again
the situation worsens for the 6500 XT at
1440p and now even with PCI Express 4.0
we can't achieve a 40 FPS average
meanwhile the RTX 3050 fell just shy of
60 FPS and was again seen matching the
super the Watchdogs Legion results were
quite good for the radiant RX 6500 XT
when using the medium quality preset but
here the RTX 350 was good for 88 FPS and
that did make it 177% faster than the
6500 XT or 28% faster when comparing the
PCI 3.0 result so admittedly that is a
big win for NVIDIA when compared to the
1660 super it was just 5% faster and
then 15% slower than the 5600 XT and RTX
2060 so a little disappointing there
when compared to those older models
again though the RTX 350 does race away
with it at 1440p averaging just over 60
fps to make it 28% faster than the 6500
XT or 36% faster when using PCI 3.0 for
the rad on GPU it was also 10% faster
than the 1660 super but 14 to 15% slower
than the RTX 2060 and 5600
XT now for testing Rainbow Six Siege
we're using the ultra quality preset
with the HD texture pack enabled because
again the 5500 XT the 4 GB version was
used to establish the test settings and
it was good for well over 100 FPS at all
times averaging 145 FPS the RTX 3050 had
no issues crushing that result though
with 225 FPS on average making it just
11% slower than the RTX 260 and 14%
faster than the 1660 super unbelievably
it was 92% faster than the 6500 XT and
let's not even bother with the PCI 3.0
result for that
GPU moving to 1440p sees the RTX 350
beat the 6500 XT by an embarrassing 110%
margin as it was again able to slot in
between the 1660 super and RTX 2060 hell
it was only 10% slower than the RX
6600 for whatever reason the 6500 XT was
even worse than expected in F1 2021 and
I suspect the issue is PCI Express
bandwidth but whatever the case the RTX
3050 was 52% faster at 1080p using the
second highest quality preset with 141
FPS on average and then PCI 3.0
completely crippled the 6500 XT and now
the RTX 3050 is seen to be
114% faster and I should note that I got
the exact same result using PCI 3.0 with
the
3050 moving to 1440p again increases the
margin in favor of the 3050 which is now
66% faster than the 500 XT when using
PCI 4.0 and 128% faster than the PCI 3.0
configuration we're also looking at
slightly better performance than the GTX
1660 super next we have Horizon zero
Dawn and here the 6500 XT using PC 4.0
did very well relative to most other
games with 72 FPS on average and that
meant that the RTX 3050 was just 14%
faster though with both using p Express
3.0 the G force GPU would be a massive
55% faster and as you'd expect the
margins did open up at 1440p and now the
RTX 350 is 24% faster than the 6500 XT
it was also a few frames faster than the
1660 super and Trail the RTX 260 by a
15% margin moving on to Far Cry 6 we
find an average of 96 FPS when using the
GeForce RTX 350 at 1080p with the medium
quality preset so as we've seen multiple
times already it is basically delivering
1660 super performance though it wasn't
a great deal slower than the RTX 2060 in
this one at least when comparing the
average frame rate meanwhile the 6500 XT
also turns in one of its better
performances in Far Cry 6 and as a
result the 350 was just 14% faster
though again the issue with the 6500 XT
is PCI Express 3.0 and when compared to
that configuration the 3050 was 37%
faster the 6500 XT does crumble at 1440p
where the RTX 3050 remains quite strong
turning in over 60 FPS on average to
make it 42% faster Doom maternal was a
really rough title for the 6500 XT and
this was especially true when using PC
3.0 the RTX 350 on the other hand it
does extremely well here matching the
RTX 2060 with 178 FPS in average and
that meant it was 82% faster than the
6500 XT and
28 7% faster than the PCI 3.0
configuration so that's that's really
quite something and it's really probably
all we need to say about that 1440p is
as you'd expect an ugly Affair for the
6500 XT and it's disappointing to see
that the 4 GB rx570 could hit 60 FPS for
what was a very playable experience the
6500 XT though using PCI 3.0 was reduced
to just 36 FPS the RTX 350 had no such
issues though pumping out a super
impressive 130 FPS while keeping 1% lows
above 100 FPS it was also 133% faster
than the RTX 260 and just 11% slower
than the RX 6600 so a fairly Stellar
result there Resident Evil Village isn't
a very demanding game especially with
the balance quality preset so it's no
surprise that at 1080p the RTX 3050 is
Comfortably pushing over 100 FPS
averaging 114 FPS again this is very GTX
1660 super light performance and AD
meant that the new GeForce GPU was 52%
faster than the 6500 XT or 78% faster if
we compare the PCI 3.0
configuration next up we have death
stranding and this is another game that
isn't terribly demanding despite looking
quite good overall the GTX 3050 was good
for 108 FPS on average using the default
quality preset at 1080P and that placed
it directly between the 1660 super and
RTX 2060 so a great result there it was
also 24% faster than the 6500 XT and
dropping the radi on graphics card down
to PCI 3.0 only extended that margin of
27% so you could certainly argue this is
a good result for the radon GPU even at
1440p the 6500 XT hangs in there
averaging 64 fps to the RTX 350s 79 FPS
which only made the GeForce GPU 23%
faster and given the difference in price
even at MSRP that's a good result for
AMD the x350 rendered 112 FPS on average
in Hitman 3 using the medium quality
preset at 1080P and that again placed it
very close to the RTX 2060 in fact it
was just 3% slow in the 2060 while it
beat the 1660 super by 23% margin it was
also 29% faster than the 6500 XT or 42%
faster when restricted to PC
3.0 even at 1440p the RTX 350 still
managed well over 60 FPS and that made
it 9% faster than the RTX 2060 and 35%
faster than the 6500 XT so a great
result here given the current
market last up we have cyberpunk 2077
and here the RTX 350 managed to break
the 60 FPS barrier with the medium
quality preset averaging 60 FPS which
all things considered is actually quite
a good result unfortunately it was 18%
sold in the RTX 2060 but it was also 40%
faster than the 6500 XT or 69% faster
when using PCI 3.0
those margins remained much the same at
1440p here the RTX 3050 was 37% faster
than the 6500 XT or 58% faster when
using PCI 3.0 it did only manage 41 FPS
on average so for this game I'd say the
3050 is better suited for 1080p
gameplay like the Radeon RX 6500 XT the
GeForce RTX 350 is very light on power
pushing total system usage just 277 wats
in our Doom benchmark
so given the resulting performance that
makes it much more efficient than the
6500 XT but even if we take a more
favorable game such as death stranding
or maybe even Hitman 3 the 3050 still
Stacks up well as it only increased
total system usage over the 6500 XT by
15% now although I mentioned earlier
that the RTX 350 delivers the exact same
level of performance using either PCI
3.0 or 4.0 here's a quick example of
this please note I did test all 12 games
and found nothing outside of the margin
of error though most results were
exactly the same whereas the 6500 XT Dro
performance by 133% with PCI 3.0 we see
absolutely no change for the RTX 3050 so
that means for gamers limited to PCI 3.0
the RTX 3050 is going to be
significantly faster than the 6500
XT and here's a look at the 12 game
average data which has been calculated
using the geom mean the RTX 350 averaged
108 FPS at 1080P and this meant that it
was just 5% faster than the 1660 super
10% slower than the RTX 2060 and 203%
slower than the RX
6600 when compared to the 6500 XT though
we're looking at a 37% performance boost
or a massive 74% increase when compared
to the PCI 3.0 result as we often saw
the 440p data is even more brutal for
the 6500 XT as here the RTX 3050 was 54%
faster already 5% f fast when comparing
the PCI 3.0 performance the 350 also
aage 74 FPS so more often than not it's
going to be good for over 60 FPS at
1440p using respectable quality
settings okay so what about rate racing
performance personally I don't feel as
though the RTX 350's rasterization
performance is nearly powerful enough to
justify turning on R tracing but you can
and some of you might want to so let's
take a look at that starting with
Watchdogs Legion we see that stock the
RTX 3050 was good for 88 FPS on average
with the dialed down medium quality
preset enabling dlss without enabling
rtfx is really quite a big help here
boosting the average frame rate by 26%
to 111 FPS and we're now looking at RX
6600 light performance turning on R
tracing with the medium quality settings
plus dlss dropped the average frame rate
to 60 FPS so still very playable but
personally I'd rather play the game with
a higher quality prese set and perhaps
leave dlss enabled anyway the game was
still playable with r tracing enabled
plus dlss delivering around 60 FPS on
average without the aid of dlss though
frame rates dropped into the low 40s and
that's about the same level of Road
tracing performance you can expect from
the RX 6600 in this
title testing with Far Cry 6 which
doesn't support dlss sees the RTX 350
still able to comfortably break the
60fps barrier with rate tracing fully
enabled
it was slower than the much more
expensive RX 6600 but whereas it was 28%
slower without RT enabled it was just
14% slower with it
enabled finally we have cyberpunk 2077
and again we find that dlss is the most
impressive feature here boosting
rasterization performance by an
incredible 48% allowing the 3050 to beat
the RX
6600 then using R tracing without dlss
enabled saw the RTX 3050 and rx6 600
both delivering comparable performance
with between 30 to 40 FPS but of course
enabling dlss offered a big performance
boost here and now the 3050 was good for
around 60 FPS on average finally for
those of you wondering why I compared
with the RX 6600 and not the 6500 XT for
R tracing benchmarks it's because I'm
just not that cruel seriously though the
6500 XT is so weak with ra tracing
enabled that the data isn't even useful
for comparison
okay time for the all important cost per
frame analysis and I'm going to start
with the MSRP using the 1080p data but I
will include the 40 and 40p results for
the more realistic real world price in
comparison which I'll make in a moment
but let's get the fantasy land stuff out
of the way first if the RTX 3050 was to
sell for the $250 us MSRP which it
obviously weren't but if it did it would
smoke the $200 6500 XT offering a
discount of 9% per frame or 28% when
comparing the PCI 3.0 data that said it
would also be much worse value than the
GTX 1650 super and slightly worse than
the RX 6500 XT but that's to be expected
given the current market so we can
accept a little bit of stagnation here
though we still don't like it now if we
look at real world pricing the situation
is quite different for the used gpus
we're taking the average sale price seen
over at ebay.com for the past 4 weeks
and for new gpus the pricing is based on
we could find in stock at places like
newegg.com this places the 6500xd at
$270 us but we're expecting the RTX 3050
to cost at least $450 us so please take
note that that is an educated guess at
this point in time given the cards
aren't yet on sale so with the 6500 XT
currently selling for at least 35% over
the MSRP we're expecting the RTX 3050
will come in at a much larger 80%
premium but hopefully it is less than
that
still even at $450 the RTX 350 is better
value for PCI 3.0 owners as it reduces
the cost per frame by 4% while also
including a number of important features
that said if you have PCI 4.0 and don't
require any of the missing features of
the 6500 XT and are willing to sacrifice
some visual quality in order to achieve
acceptable performance You could argue
that the 6500 XT is better value at $270
us as it was 18% cheaper per frame than
the RTX 3050 but for me that's a serious
stretch given everything else you get
with the gForce
GPU also if you're targeting entry level
1440p gaming the RTX 3050 is without
question the superior product vastly
Superior in my opinion not only are you
likely to be pushing well over 60 FPS
with the GeForce GPU but it was also
just 8% more expensive per frame when
compared to the 6500 X in the PCI 4.0
mode so for those of you gaming at 1440p
even if priced at $450 us the RTX 3050
is a much much better value product and
well worth spending the extra money on
or saving up
for that said it's also well worth
keeping in mind that at this price point
the RX 6600 is technically better value
as it cost just 24% more but offers 26%
more performance granted they are about
the same in terms of value but when
spending this much the RX 6600 does
become a viable
alternative okay so while we fear that
the RTX 350 will likely end up around
$450 us or possibly more and we've seen
that even there it's generally better
value than the 6500 XT what price does
it need to be before no one can argue
that the 6500 XT has any value I believe
that figure is around
$370 us which is likely wishful thinking
but if Nvidia pulled that off it would
be extremely embarrassing for AMD at
$370 the 3050 would be on par with the
6500 XT using PC 4.0 in terms of cost
per frame using our 1080p data while
offering twice as much vrm twice as much
PCI bandwidth better decoding support
actual encoding support and more than
two display outputs so I really can't
see the 3050 being that competitive on
pricing but anywhere between 370 and
$450 is going to be rough for the 6500
XT so how desirable the GeForce RTX 350
ends up being will depend entirely on
pricing and availability if it ends up
costing $500 US then it's going to be a
big old fat nothing Burger in my opinion
and you might as well just get the
faster radon RX 6600 so it is really
difficult to say just how excited you
should get about the RTX 3050 but based
on the performance just seen we know
exactly where it should be PR in order
to make sense but making sense isn't
really something the GPU Market seems to
do anymore now we expected the 6500 XT
to come in at around $300 us where we
believed it would suck and it did
slightly better hitting $270 us at least
for now but still ultimately sucks at
that price despite being the cheapest
new graphics card you can get your hands
on we recommend you either continue to
hold out or buy secondhand and frankly
the rx570 4 GB for $220 used is a
significantly better compromise and
hands down the best option for those of
you still using a PCI 3.0 system which
again we suspect is the vast majority of
you now as for the RTX 3050 we're
expecting that part to come in for at
least $450 us but with the RTX 3060
selling on average for a 112% premium
over MSRP anything's possible as noted
earlier we strongly believe that the
3050 needs to be priced at around 3 $7
to be a great deal in the current market
and really the go-to option for PC
Gamers at that price it would be
unbeatable even when looking at the
secondhand Market which sees the
similarly performing 1660 super going
for $470 us so again based on that the
unfortunate reality is that the 3050 is
probably going to cost more like $500 US
if that's the case then you're really
best off being upsold to the RX 6600 or
perhaps the smarter option would be to
look for a cheaper secondhand option
just to tie you over having said all of
that though I do feel as though the RTX
3050 at $500 is a much better investment
than the 6500 XT at $270 despite the
fact that we don't recommend you
purchase either of them at those prices
and the reason for this is quite simple
the RTX 3050 will typically offer more
value to PCI 3.0 users which right now
as I said is most Gamers and then you
have all the extra features on top of
that that I've already spoken of
and another consideration is one that a
lot of the 6500 XT apologists have
overlooked and that's future proofing a
point that we generally make fun of as
it's often heavily overused or done so
with an unreasonable time frame for
example FX processors would be better
than sandybridge in 10 years time but
I'm not talking about 10 years or five
or even three rather I fully expect that
within the next 2 years we're going to
come across games that the 65 XT is
really going to struggle to play even
with the lowest quality settings and I
expect that older 4 GB graphics cards
like the gtx650 super or 5500 XT will
work just fine while the RX 6600 and RTX
3050 will still be very capable so how
much value do you place on longevity the
ability to buy a graphics card now and
still have it delivering respectable
performance in 2 years time this is what
made the RX 580 so great and I believe
it's what will make the 6500 XT even
worse than what most reviewers have
reported to date and that's certainly
saying something anyway for now we're
just going to have to wait and see where
the RTX 350 lands in terms of pricing
and availability that they sort of go
hand in hand Tim and I are also getting
together shortly to do an updated video
looking at the 6500 XT and RTX 350 kind
of a discussion opinion piece type deal
we'll talk about pricing there uh other
reviews or just General sentiment around
those those product launchers and yeah
should be an interesting topic but
that'll be on the main channel so you
guys will be able to see that and then
we also have well Tim's monthly GPU
pricing update so that will be coming
sometime next month and that should be
very interesting to see where those two
products end up Landing in about a month
from now so yeah make sure you
subscribed for all of that and of course
if you do have the chance if you do have
the honor of grabbing an RTX 3050 at the
MSRP I feel there'll be very few people
that are able to do that but if you are
definitely go for it I I think it's well
worth jumping on that one and really if
you can get it for any price below $400
I think for those of you've been holding
out it's really really worth grabbing at
that price but as I said it'll be
interesting to see where it does settle
in and we'll be covering that shortly
but yeah like subscribe do all that
stuff and if you'd like to become a
harun box Community member and get some
access to some pretty cool stuff such as
our exclusive Discord server monthly
live streams which again Tim and I will
be doing one of those shortly for the
float plane and patreon members behind
the scenes content and Q&A then yet
check us out float plane patreon links
are in the video description but if not
that is perfectly fine and I would like
to thank you for watching this video I'm
your host Steve and I'll see you again
next time
[Music]